[Música]
hoy te de tu interés
cámara harry se convirtió en la primera
vicepresidenta electa de eeuu la primera
además afro asiática que se sienta en
ese puesto
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 hoy
vamos a conversar de lo que representa a
ella la demócrata que rompió barreras de
género y de desigualdad y que hoy por
fin le da a la mujer un puesto
protagónico en la economía más
importante del planeta de fiscal a
senadora y luego a vicepresidenta ya y
su historia ahora tiene el compromiso de
mostrar que su valía no pasa por una
cuota femenina
una mujer afro de ascendencia asiática
su nombre significa fortuna y
constantemente recuerda que nadie más
que ella misma creará su futuro aquí la
historia de kamala harris y las
polémicas de su carrera
durante 56 años la dualidad ha definido
a kamala harris nació en oakland pero
sus padres son inmigrantes de jamaica e
india- la educaron hindú pero eligió sal
protestante creció entre manifestaciones
pero rehusó ser activista como su madre
se hizo abogada y luego fiscal para
cambiar el sistema desde adentro así lo
dijo en junio al 'new york times'
consciente de su apuesta en el hinduismo
kamala significa fortuna y de 2004 2011
dirigió esta hacia su cargo de fiscal de
distrito en san francisco donde creó un
programa de reinserción de presos cree
que enfrentar las desigualdades
judiciales y a la vez ser firme contra
el crimen es posible y con esa certeza
de 2011 a 2016 ascendió a fiscal general
de california pero de nuevo lo dual la
contradicción marcaron su legado
judicial se opuso a la pena de muerte
para un hombre que mató a un policía
pero defendió la pena capital en el
sistema penal de su estado quiso poner
cámaras en los uniformes pero poco
proceso a policías la muerte de civiles
ha defendido la justicia racial pero
como fiscal incrementó los
encarcelamientos
en 2017 se convirtió en senadora por
california en la cámara alta completó su
fama siendo una dura interrogadora
su siguiente objetivo fue la presidencia
su campaña decayó en 2019 no sin antes
dejar un combativo debate en las
primarias ante un joe biden que se jactó
de haber trabajado con senadores
segregacionistas
james jones
station freeze el descanso pero fue ese
espíritu crítico además de su mezcla
cultural lo que hizo que bailen la
incluyera en su equipo a excepto una
mansión vice president of the night
state de marca por todo ello kamala
harris es una historia de éxito en eeuu
la confirmación de que una mujer de raza
mixta de origen inmigrante y que apela a
los derechos civiles puede estar al
frente de la política del país perfilar
su carácter desde las más altas esferas
será su siguiente tarea inicia nuestra
conversación en ellas hoy nos acompaña a
mariel y lópez santana catedrática
asociada y directora del programa
graduado de ciencias políticas en el
sars school of policy and government en
george mason university marialy
bienvenida a ellas hoy gracias por estar
con nosotros y comienzo parece increíble
que el país que se jacta de ser la
democracia más grande
y además una nación libre construida por
inmigrantes apenas en el 2020 le dio la
confianza a una mujer para la
vicepresidencia
primero que nada muchas gracias por la
invitación es un honor para mí para
estar aquí si yo creo que es muy certero
lo que estás diciendo pasaron más de 35
de años hasta que los demócratas
volvieron a escoger a una mujer como
vicepresidenta primero vimos en 1984 que
se escogió una mujer como para correr
para como prescribir ser presidenta pero
no es hasta kamala harris y si tomamos
en cuenta
sarpei link cuando los republicanos le
escogieron pues no
pensamos de tela en 1980 solamente ha
habido tres mujeres y como ya sabemos
pues está mal aris es la única que ha
sido exitosa en términos de volverse
vicepresidenta
e invitar para que escuchemos antes de
continuar con las preguntas precisamente
una parte muy interesante que dijo
durante su discurso de la victoria de
joe biden
diferentes aves y humanos
aunque sea la primera mujer en este
cargo no será la última
[Aplausos]
watson porque cada niña que está viendo
esto podrá ver que este es un país de
posibilidades
[Música]
y a los niños de nuestro país sin
importar su género nuestro país les ha
enviado un mensaje sueñen con ambiciones
lideren con sus convicciones y vean se
en una forma en la que otros puedan no
verlos simplemente porque nunca han
visto que suceda es menos simple
ibéricas weiner rising que fue muy
acertado muy certero muy real lo que
dice kamala harris y que es un mensaje
que llega directamente a las más
pequeñas que esperamos ella y nosotras
que estamos aquí pues les abramos paso
para que no tengan que sufrir las
dificultades que hay con la brecha de
género con la desigualdad con la
obligación de tener cuotas femeninas en
el mundo usted cómo ve esta figura que
se posiciona hoy y es un ejemplo
femenino
yo creo que ya una figura trascendental
como podemos ver en las primarias en
desde el punto de vista los demócratas
pues existe más presión para que haya
más representación de las mujeres en la
política aún dentro de partidos
demócratas según vi unas cifras
recientemente si vemos por ejemplo el
porcentaje de personas de color que
salen desde partido demócrata no llega
ni a 1 a un 400 puntos 9% así que desde
este punto de vista no solamente porque
ellas mujeres sino también porque es una
mujer como han dicho unas mujeres de
color que representa unas minorías su
posición como vicepresidenta es
trascendental para no solamente poder
poder promover los los asuntos que
tienen que ver con las mujeres como
podemos decir los asuntos de salud que
pueden dar diferentes tipos de políticas
sociales a las mujeres para que estén
mejor dentro de muchas posiciones pero
también en términos de dar
representación a las personas de color
en este país que el como sabemos pues
han estado muy poco representadas
a nivel público o sea que ella juega va
a jugar esos dos roles a la misma vez lo
que le dicen los politólogos y los
sociólogos este punto de vista de la
imperfección entre punto de vista género
y también un punto de vista de su raza y
su etnia y no la verdad no varía el iii
y aquí acotar que de hecho ella
agradeció directamente no solamente a
los votantes afroamericanos sino a las
mujeres votantes afro que pues se
pusieron su mano adelante por ella y
dice kamala harris que estaba lista
junto a job aid n para combatir el
racismo sistémico este es un tema en el
que vamos a estar muy detrás de sus
pasos porque es una urgencia histórica
que aún no se logra solucionar este año
hemos visto manifestaciones que también
son históricas por los derechos humanos
por los derechos de las personas
afroamericanas usted como vaticina que
sean su gestión en este sentido y pues
es saber si se va a quedar o no en las
palabras de la campaña recordemos que no
es lo mismo la promesa que ya ejerciendo
el cargo
no estoy totalmente de acuerdo con que
ella va a jugar y también claro va a ir
en va a jugar un papel trascendental en
términos de poder definir y también
implementar una agenda que se trate de
promover el like well igualdad no
solamente de las mujeres pero también de
las personas de color como sabemos el
asunto de la violencia policiaca es un
asunto que es tan número uno sobre todo
entre las personas que atañen si vamos
desde el perfil de los demócratas claro
desde el punto de vista de los
republicanos existe muchas
y mucha disposición al no ver esos
problemas de ves las 5 sistémicos que
existen en este país así que ella tanto
como vayan a jugar un papel transplantan
a entrar en tratar de tener una
conversación con los trompistas y
también con los republicanos para poder
tratar de reformar el sistema sobre todo
policiaco verdad
en eeuu
a mi parecer es un asunto trascendental
porque no solamente tiene que ver con la
violencia en contra de las minorías
raciales sino también con asuntos de
desigualdad de políticas públicas de
salud y muchas cosas que atañen a toda
esta población claro y aquí el
comentario marialy es qué cámara ha sido
criticada por inconsistente en el pasado
cuando ejerció como fiscal en el tema
por ejemplo de la pena de muerte y
también particularmente en la aplicación
de justicia para los ciudadanos
afroamericanos así que en este momento
pues ella tiene que salir al frente y
dar una muestra de cómo va a ser esa
lucha por la igualdad en los eeuu y
particularmente por la lucha de los
afroamericanos ya llegamos al final del
programa este tiempo se pasa rapidísimo
pero para el cierre yo quisiera que
rápidamente usted nos diga este es un
paso más hacia la presidencia podríamos
esperar que tal vez para la siguiente
elección presidencial de kamala harris
ya no fuera la fórmula
la candidata para ocupar la oficina oval
y el puesto más importante como
presidente de una de las economías más
grandes
bueno la pregunta es si yo vayan va a
volver a postularse para presidente hay
gente que ha dicho que sí pero sabemos
que si yo vaya en gana de nuevo tendría
cerca de 86 años cuando termine el
segundo ciclo de la presidencia o sea
que para mí es muy posible que ya sea la
próxima candidata
es natural de que ya sea las caminatas y
vemos cómo se dan los ciclos
presidenciales es muy común que los
vicepresidentes como vemos en el caso de
baile vuelvan y se sean las personas que
vayan aa
a correr dentro de esa posición como
presidente así que no me sorprendería
para nada que ella sea la próxima
candidata para la presidencia en el
próximo ciclo de 2024 marialy pues
muchas gracias a ustedes por su análisis
y a partir del 20 de enero empieza a
contar el reloj o para ver cómo será la
gestión de kamala harris sigan con
nosotros en france 24 nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]